so the Prime Minister and the chancellor
are on their way to meet the obr's
Richard Hughes today
when was the last time a prime minister
went to meet the obr like this it's
pretty unprecedented isn't it a sign of
the real crisis that we're in
well it seems to be a very good idea
that the Prime Minister and Chancellor
are sitting down with the independent
obr
um just like the Independent Bank of
England you know they've got a really
important role to play we all want the
forecasts to be as quickly as as they
can but also as a former Finance
director I know that you also want them
to have the right level of detail so
that that's where we are in that process
we had to act fast because if we hadn't
have acted tomorrow the first of October
was when in Energy prices were going to
rise across uh the whole United Kingdom
damaging businesses and households so we
had to act a week ago today it's really
important that we work as we are handing
glove with the Independent Bank of
England and the obr to now put the
forecasts in place uh move through this
you say you had to act fast you'd
already announced the energy package to
support people with Rising prices you
didn't have to push ahead with a raft of
tax cuts that were unfunded and without
the Obi analysis alongside which would
have shown how much it would cost and
how it was going to be paid for which
might have reassured the market
well with respect the way it's going to
be paid for is by coming forward with
the plan for growth So the plan for
growth was a detailed set of measures
people needed didn't the markets need to
see the obr spelling that out well
there's 40 pages of detail in the growth
plan I'm sure you've read that and the
obr's read that but there's a lot of
detail to work through there's a very
significant set of supply-side measures
to help the economy there's measures to
help prevent strikes that are just
grinding this country to a halts we
we've heard this week the labor party
want to give more rights to people to
strike within our growth plan is
reducing the right to strike so that we
can keep the economy moving so with
respect if all we've done is come up
with just the energy measures important
and critical And Timely though they were
then you'd be sitting here asking us how
we're going to get the economy growing
the obr wouldn't be able to reflect that
economics plan in their numbers as well
that's what the markets want to hear
they want to hear that we're all work
working tightly together as we are I
think the chancellor and the bank of
England Governor have spoken every day
this week okay but also how we can put
the credible plans in place uh that we
need going forward so if you accept that
the markets need to see the government
and the obr working close together do
you accept then it was a mistake not to
release an assessment from the obr at
the same time as the mini budget yes or
no
but under the obr at that point wouldn't
have had access to the growth plan they
confirmed last night that they could
have produced a forecast in time for the
mini budget well that forecast wouldn't
have had
um the growth measures in that plan they
would have been finalized in the hours
before the chancellor stood up it was
right that he did that first in
Parliament and there's a very
significant amount of supply-side
measures that now over the coming weeks
and if you said before as quickly as
possible but in as much detail as
necessary to give the credibility to
those plans that the obr will want to be
reflecting that significant supply side
reform you know getting our energy uh
new the the transition to a new clean
energy uh going at real Pace uh building
some of the infrastructure that hasn't
been built for many years making sure
that we're bringing more affordable
housing to the market you've got to look
at all of that in the round and the the
forecast the OVR could have produced in
advance would have been a static
forecast that wouldn't have had the
ability to reflect the growth plan that
the Chancellor's brought forward okay so
there's this meeting going on today with
the obr will we see a report from them
ahead of that November the 23rd day that
the chancellor has given us so far will
that be brought forward
well I think Anna the point about an
independent obr is that they've got to
be given the freedom and ability to do
that I'm sure if they could they they
would and that's a decision for them uh
but it's not for me or anyone else to
dictate that to them
so we might get one before if the obr
decides to produce one that's what
you're saying well what I'm saying is is
we've got to respect the independent obr
and and with respect I'm not coming on
Sky News to to tell or ask the obr what
to do it's a shared Endeavor we need to
provide the the necessary detail of our
plans that's what we are focused on uh
and then the obr will want to do do
their job and do that with the right
degree of diligence uh to be able to
come up with their forecasts it's not
easy there are lots of moving Parts uh
controlling Infamous inflation is not
easy uh the impacts of the supply chain
of Putin's aggression in Ukraine is
cascading through many parts of the
economy government's got a comprehensive
set of measures designed to deal with
the immediate crisis in energy and to
grow the economy thereafter uh going
into this you know remember we we start
this in a strong position we have the
second lowest level of debt to GDP of
any of the G7 Nations and our economy is
strong resilient and flexible and yeah
we've had Chaos on the market it's we've
seen the the pound slump we've seen
chaos in the bond market as well that
has seen an unprecedented move by the
bank of England to intervene what did
spook the market what would you say the
reason was now
well we've seen difficulties in in lots
of international markets this week uh
obviously the the UK has been quite
challenging uh but the German inflation
figures that came out yesterday were an
unprecedented unprecedented level of
German inflation 11 that's the highest
uh since the single currency uh ever
came to being I suspect it's one of the
highest uh in German history earlier
this week we saw the Nordstrom pipeline
that this time last year would have been
putting 160 million cubic liters of gas
coming from Russia to Europe to help
power all of our energy
um you know yes yesterday there were
zero liters of gas coming through that
pipeline so we're in a period you've got
to look a little bit about the wider
context that we're in okay well
you you're still saying that it's down
to Global pressures but at Hugh pill
who's the bank of England's Chief
economy Anna I agree with you and he he
was very clear that there's
um uh and this this is UK specific
component the thing that is being seen
no no you that's not fair to
misrepresent Hugh Hugh was very clear uh
that this is something that all major
Global economies are seeing um of course
this particular week we've we've seen
more movement in the UK than others but
if we look overall at the trajectory of
interest rates for example going into
this week uh the UK had seen a lower
increase in interest rates uh than most
other major economies uh now there's
been a degree of of catching up well yes
he talked about the global picture but
he said there is undoubtedly a UK
specific component and and there are
there are members of the of the
conservative party who are unhappy with
the way the government is putting this
solely down to Global issues and we've
got Lord Frost saying today if they want
to establish confidence with them
markets ministers must be honest in what
they say yes Global conditions are part
of the story but it's obvious last
week's statement calls the crash we've
got Julian Smith MP former Chief whip
the government must scrap 45p take
responsibility for the link between last
Friday and the impact on people's
mortgages and make clear that it will do
everything possible to stabilize markets
and protect public services do you
accept what they say there
and what I'd say to colleagues is you
know this is a difficult time for all
all developed economies and and for all
governments this is a government that's
taken decisive steps to deal with the
immediate energy crisis and I would just
ask people to look at what the
opposition party has been saying they've
been up in Liverpool this week the
biggest Round of Applause they had was
for the nationalization of an energy
company they've committed themselves to
increase the energy insecurity of this
country by turning off every last cubic
meter of North Sea gas by 2030. I think
that's the wrong decision and then
tomorrow we're going to see another wave
of national strikes this government
wants to reduce the ability of Strikers
to bring this country to a halt uh the
labor party we want to give them more
rights okay let me talk a little bit
about spending because there's going to
be a huge squeeze on public spending it
isn't there not least because of inflate
station rising at the levels that it is
will benefits rise in line with
inflation can we be clear and clarify
that position
well this is the government that's on
the side of the most vulnerable you saw
that in the cost of living measures that
we brought forward this this earlier the
richest
every household will get 400 pounds but
the most vulnerable 8 million will get 1
200 pounds so I think you can look at
our actions there there'll be a normal
operating process that's followed
that'll make those decisions in due
course so again that's not one for this
morning Anna but that normal process
will go through none of these choices
are easy uh the biggest fiscal
intervention that this government has
made is that energy package that means
from Tomorrow the first of October when
bills would otherwise be going up the
bills for the average household uh will
now be around 2 500 pound that's
significantly less and it's giving
everybody in the economy businesses and
households the confidence to get on and
do what they need to do just
why why is it possible to announce a a
cut in the top rate of income tax for
the richest people but it's not possible
to confirm whether or not benefits will
rise with inflation I don't understand
why one decision can be made the other
one we have to wait for but there's a
normal there's a normal process around
the annual round of how benefits are
uprighted um that's not something that
habitually and normally they would rise
with inflation normally one wouldn't sit
here at 7 14 on Sky News with respect
Anna and announce the uh the normal up
rating package for benefits that'll be
for ministers and secretaries of state
to decide over the coming weeks using
the normal process
and what about the squeeze on on public
services there are some suggesting that
given the the commitments that have been
made as far as tax cuts are concerned uh
given at the rise in inflation there's
going to have to be a real squeeze and
it could be in line with the the
austerity measures that we saw those
years ago
well that's speculation what I know
because what has been said by the
chancellor is that he's absolutely
committed to the current spending round
the comprehensive spending round uh
that's been in place for some time now
um and he's confirmed that he's not
reopening that so that will see Public
Services continue to be funded uh
consistent with what's in that spending
review
what do you make of this latest poll
that's come out the yougov poll that
gives labor a 33 point lead that would
suggest if there was an election
tomorrow there'd be a Tory Wipeout it
has this government already lost the
confidence of the public
well the public will decide that but
what I would use that poll as as a
reason to look in detail at Labor's
policies
um customers citizens across the country
that aren't going to get their posts
delivered tomorrow that aren't going to
be able to take the train to work or
visit family can make their view about
whether the thing that the country needs
is more rights for striking workers
whether when a lot of our economic
challenges and headwinds are due to the
lack of energy in security I mean the
exception here is the dollar the dollar
is very strong because the U.S has great
energy security and energy Independence
we don't we're on that Journey this
government's done a great deal to bring
more renewable energy uh to come forward
I don't think what we need when we're
trying to attract more investment into
our renewable clean energy sector it is
a nationalized Energy company that will
deter that investment or a a virtue
signaling commitment to turn off every
last drop of North Sea gas by 2030 that
will put us make us more vulnerable as
an economy that's what we heard from
labor this week if that's what people
want uh then they they know where to get
it I don't think that's what's right for
our economy
party conference starts this weekend
doesn't it how difficult do you think
it's going to be going in with poll
leads like that for labor and with a
number of Tory MPS fairly unhappy about
the direction the government's taken so
far
well I'm really looking forward to the
conservative conference looking forward
to hearing from all of the secretary's
estate the exciting sell side supply
side reforms in their area whether
that's improving child care whether it's
building more homes more affordable
homes in the right places whether it's
looking at how we can really unleash the
potential of the economy uh science and
Innovation superpower I'm very excited
you look across the uh the piece if you
if you look through the 40 pages of this
growth plan about how we're going to get
the economy growing again I think
there's a lot of detail there and I'm
looking forward to some of that being
revealed next week